bonjour à tous parlement hebdo se
transforme en régionale hebdo émission
spéciale consacrée au bilan de ce
premier tour analyse et stratégie de
chaque camp avec kaiser bonjour katia
bonjour michael est notre invité cette
semaine pour commenter cette actualité
chargée
roland cayrol bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous reviendrons sur les
temps forts de la semaine et sur les
scénarios possibles
alors le second tour on commence katia
avec les résultats de la phase iib la
carte de france de ce premier tour dans
six régions
le front national est arrivé en tête
dans quatre pour les républicains et
trois pour la gauche le rapport de force
politique au niveau national rappelle de
des résultats la france s'installe dans
une forme de tripartisme avec 27 27 %
des voix au niveau national pour le
front national les listes de droite et
du centre en deuxième position avec 27
5%
suit la gauche le parti socialiste avec
23 25% est ce que aux lentilles royce
avait été surpris de ces résultats
oui je crois que tout le monde a été un
peu surpris jeudi un peu parce que il y
avait aussi des vainqueurs dans cette
élection c'est les sondages qui avaient
été bons on critique
voilà vous avez remarqué donc on a
pendant toute la campagne
on a vu tout de même se dessiner très
bien les lignes et au niveau national et
au niveau de chacune des régions de ce
qui allait se passer avec notamment cet
effet attentat qui a visiblement entre
entre avant et après il ya eu quatre as
un point de glissements pour le front
national s'est visiblement liée à cette
période est ce que l'on peut dire que le
tripartisme s'est installée en france
écoutez on peut dire en tout cas qu'il
ya trois grandes forces politiques
tripartie c'est un peu tôt parce que
c'est une pour chaque saut et
spécialistes disent tripartition parce
que la gauche s'est pas uni
elle est électoralement dans un certain
nombre de cas au second tour mais autant
les républicains ont réussi à faire une
coalition total autant le front national
est évidemment unis autant la gauche
donc là il ya le parti socialiste et le
reste et le reste n'est pas en bonne
forme dans cette élection puisque si on
prend les dernières régionales en 2010
les noms socialiste que j'ai autant que
les socialistes pratiquement moitié
moitié
alors là cette fois ci la gauche de la
gauche s'est effondré de moitié par
rapport à 2010 alors quelles stratégies
justement face au front national
c'est la question en début de semaine à
la une dans les états majors dès
dimanche soir les principaux partis ont
arrêté leur stratégie manuel valls côté
nicolas sarkozy de l'autre
deux hommes deux stratégies des
positions donc divergentes
elsa mon mac à un combat à distance par
plateaux de télévision interposée
hier manuel valls et nicolas sarkozy ont
acté leur différence sur la stratégie à
adopter face au front national en région
paca
j'appelle à voter pour christian estrosi
face à l'extrême droite dans la région
nord pas de calais picardie
j'appelle à voter pour xavier bertrand
face à l'extrême droite et dans la
grande région est alsace lorraine
champagne ardenne j'appelle à voter pour
philippe richert face à l'extrême droite
qui ne peut pas l'emporter n'y aura pas
de fusion avec les socialistes et pas de
retrait il n'y a pas d'accord entre nous
il y aura pas de combines les
socialistes ont pris une décision que je
respecte
c'est leur choix ils l'ont fait sont
tous leur demandions rien dans la clarté
de leurs décisions et nous nous avons
fait un choix de maintenir nos listes
parce que je suis persuadé que nous
sommes les seuls à pouvoir rassembler
face au front national défense de ses
positions et attaques contre l'autre
camp moi j'assume mes responsabilités
c'est la grande différence avec nicolas
sarkozy entre nous et nicolas sarkozy
entre moi et nicolas sarkozy quand on
est un responsable public
on assume ses responsabilités et ont
choisi il n'y a pas de nini c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe c'est pas parce
mois la salade son voile à ruban
je ne veux pas d'arrangements dans le
dos des électeurs tous deux présentent
en rempart contre le front national mais
les arguments ne sont pas les mêmes le
programme de l'extrême droite
ça serait un désastre plan économique et
pour nos entreprises dans ces régions
l'extrême droite est elle divise les
français
elles veulent et jeter les uns contre
les autres donc il y a deux visions et
bien dans la plupart des régions
cette vision de la république ouverte
généreuse exigeante forte qui est là
pour protéger et rassembler c'est la
gauche et les écologistes qu'ils
apporteront l'exaspération devant la
politique menée le sentiment qu'ont les
gens se disent au fond est-ce que ces
politiques qui peuvent encore quelque
chose ou est ce qu'on peut rien il ya
une désespérance
il se demande au fond est-ce que la
france de toujours restera la france
pour faire clair c'est un peu
caricatural mais un peu de seins c'est
un simple questionnement du front
national non je suis désolé c'est
questionnements que j'ai posée dès 2000
tout ne tourne pas autour de madame le
pen de son père de sa petite fille de sa
nièce et compagnie quand j'ai parlé des
racines chrétiennes de la france bat
tendu madame le pen que les gens tendu
de la bien-pensance la république a trop
reculé
des stratégies contre le fn mise à
l'épreuve dimanche prochain alors roland
cayrol est ce que le front républicain
c'était pour le ps la seule stratégie
possible
oui d'ailleurs si on fait un peu
d'histoire électorale c'est la seule
façon de battre les extrêmes droites
dans une élection à deux tours
désistement républicain ou fusion de
deux candidatures lorsque c'est possible
nicolas sarkozy a appris le pari inverse
au fond il est sur une stratégie qui est
toujours la même depuis le deuxième tour
de la dernière élection présidentielle
qui l'a conduit à l'échec
c'est ce ni ni comme si on mettait un
signe égal entre le front national et
les autres partis républicains comme le
parti social c'est à c'est un risque
qu'il a pris il pense visiblement lui à
nouveau à la prochaine élection
présidentielle
mais c'est harry ce qu'il est il qu'il
pourrait payer dans son propre gardien
d'abord encore une fois ci ça va jusqu
aux élections mais dans la bataille de
la primaire ça va être à droite l'un des
sujets principaux de l'asie
l'expliqué très bien en local mais
pourquoi le ministre ça ne fonctionne
pas ça n'a pas fonctionné en 2012
pourquoi ça ne fonctionnera peut-être
pas cette fa circuler ça ne fonctionne
pas pour nicolas sarkozy mais lorsqu'il
ne donne pas de consignes les électeurs
rappelez vous la partielle du doubs ils
y vont et ils votent contre le front
national il faut pas oublier que tous
les sondages montrent que les deux tiers
des français ne veulent en aucun cas du
front national au pouvoir
donc on peut se servir du vote front
national d'abord au premier tour pour
dire non non et non à ce qu'on voit ce
passé où pour dire il ya trop d'arabes
ya trop de musulmans en france mais on
n'a pas envie de les installer au
pouvoir donc la stratégie du ni ni
accompagné du fait qu'on va reprendre la
thématique du front national il me
semble à moi je ne sais pas un point de
vue politique que je défends l'intérêt
serait personnes mais du point de vue de
l'analyse il me semble que c'est une
impasse
l on a vécu un moment historique ah on
avec un moment historique ce moment
politique
manuel valls appelant nommément à voter
en les citant pour trois têtes de liste
de la droite
voilà ça c'est quand même rare d'avoir
un droit et alors on a bien écouté il
l'a fait et c'est un certain courage de
dire non seulement aller j'ai demandé à
mes gens de partir et voter en face mais
d'appeler carrément à en disant des noms
tôt il aurait écorché la bouche de
beaucoup de gens nous voient ces
anticorps
c'est un certain courage politique c'est
une crânerie qui te qu'on peut écouter
ce que disent et marine le pen sur cette
île et de la stratégie du parti
socialiste cette idée du retrait écouter
le parti socialiste comme la la secte du
temple solaire a décidé d'un véritable
suicide collectif
par l'intermédiaire du retrait de ces
listes c'est leur choix
je crois que ils auront de longues
années pour regretter ce choix
marine le pen le dit avec ses mots mais
quand on regarde un petit peu plus loin
c'est vrai que le parti socialiste sera
absent dans des bastions qui était très
important pour lui pour le nord pour le
sud de la france région provence alpes
côte d'azur six ans où il n'y aura pas
d'élus socialistes
c'est vrai que par rapport à l'histoire
politique
on disait pour les fédérations
importantes du parti socialiste les les
bouches du nord pour bien montrer que
c'était sale et les deux bastions
et ce sont précisément les deux endroits
où il n'y a pas de socialisme enfin
séduit quand même d'abord à
l'effondrement électoral du parti
socialiste parce que ça reste quand même
un échec pour moi c'est un échec que
grave quand on a dominé des régions et
qu'on n'est même plus capable d'arriver
aux joues entoure le fait qu'ils aient
ou pas quelques conseillers régionaux
très minoritaire dans une assemblée
c'est rien par rapport à cette réalité
incroyable qui n'est due en rien à la
situation du front national de le
je-ne-sais-quoi qui est l'échec du
socialisme dans ces régions que ça peut
durer on voit que dans certains pays
d'europe comme la hongrie ou la pologne
et bien la gauche s'est complètement
retirée au profit de certains partis
populistes est ce que ça peut arriver
moi je crois que au niveau national le
parti socialiste est appelé à prendre
des décisions stratégiques d'ampleur est
ce que il continue sa politique
d'aggiornamento est-ce qu'il devient un
véritable parti progressiste sociale
libérale ou est ce qui reste un petit
peu marqué encore par ça c'est ce que
manuel c'est lui alors de manuel valls
macron quelques autres voilà là on sent
bien qu'il ya une évolution et qui est
que l'opinion semble demander puisque la
gauche de la gauche s'effrite d'élection
en élection
elle pèse de moins en moins donc c'est
plutôt cet axe de centre gauche que
réclament les électeurs ça au niveau
national il ya une voie qui pourrait
être tracées au niveau régional ce qui
ont été très fortement marqué par un
socialiste un peu clientéliste le vieux
socialisme municipal
ils vont rester durement atteint eux ils
ont vraiment à faire table rase alors
revenons à la droite
la stratégie du ni-ni et soutenu par une
majorité de députés à quelques
exceptions près et pas des moindres
sophie normand retrait ou fusion des
listes
la question se pose qu'en midi-pyrénées
et languedoc-roussillon où le candidat
l'est républicain est en troisième place
et à la quasi unanimité le parti répond
non nous avons fait campagne pendant des
semaines et des semaines pour dénoncer
la mauvaise gestion des équipes
socialistes à la tête des régions et
pour dénoncer aussi la politique
gouvernementale
si nous ne voulons pas tomber sous le
coup d'accusations de magouilles
partisane on va pas changer d'avis du
jour au lendemain seule nathalie
kosciusko morizet jean pierre raffarin
se sont prononcés contre cette ligne du
ni ni
moi je pense qu'il faut être très clair
que la situation est extrêmement grave
que le pays est à la dérive et
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est
mettre de l'autorité dans notre
démocratie n'est pas courir derrière les
électeurs de telle ou telle famille
politique
ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est nous
mobiliser pour sauver la république de
cette dérive
une voix discordante même si comme lui
ils sont plusieurs ténors à vouloir
ouvrir le débat sur la stratégie du
parti dès la fin du second tour
je souhaite pour après demain que nous
soyons très conscient de ce double
énoncer des français l'échec de la
gauche mais aussi l'échec et
l'impuissance de la droite telle qu'elle
s'est présentée jusqu'à présent est
telle qu'elle persiste en elle-même
depuis 2012
pointée du doigt nicolas sarkozy
certains cadres du parti critique
l'ancien chef de l'état et déplore
l'absence de leader légitime
en l'absence de leader légitime nous
n'avons pas de leader légitime dit aussi
eric woerth
est ce que la guerre des chefs est à
prévoir à droite a pressé ses régionales
oui alors là c'est très clair les
couteaux sont déjà en train de là ils
sont plus que sortir le soir voilà il
s'en sortir les voies luire dans la nuit
bon
c'est clair le prochaine étape c'est la
primaire de novembre 2016 et cette
primaire elle va être largement dominés
par l'orientation stratégique qu'il faut
donner à la droite et notamment les
relations avec le front national est ce
qu'on prend désormais vraiment comme
ennemi principal ou est ce qu'on essaye
de faire un espèce de rapprochement
thématiques qui permettrait de pipes et
ses voix on voit bien là dessus il ya
nicolas sarkozy d'à côté est
pratiquement tous les autres contre lui
parce que ils sont amenés en plus je
dirais techniquement quand on va
s'affronter à pas être d'accord sur un
sujet aussi fondamental a donc intérêt à
regarder un petit peu les chiffres 2010
il ya eu ce score qui était quasiment
équivalent à celui de 2015 la stratégie
d'alliance avec le centre
elle n'a pas vraiment fonctionné quand
vous regardez les têtes de listes
centristes dans trois régions et arrive
deuxième mais il n'y a pas vraiment de
raison que les élus centristes de ces
régions ne vois pas une partie de leur
électorat
happé par le front national comme les
républicains il n'y a pas de différence
aujourd'hui
ils sont absolument unis se présentent
ensemble je crois même que beaucoup de
personnes dans la population ne savent
pas qui est centriste et qui est
républicain se serait fait il une croix
eux parce qu'ils vivent dans leur milieu
clos politique que s'effondre c'est
d'ailleurs pour voilà fonctionné ou pas
la stratégie d'alliance elle a
fonctionné dans un climat général où
l'ensemble dépérissait et c'est ça qui
n'ont pas vu et on peut dire si on vous
demandait ce que sont les thèmes
vraiment principaux et pas seulement les
thèmes d'hostilité à tel ou tel des
républicains vous auriez du mal on a
souvent le sentiment vous rappeler la
phrase de jean marie le pen de la
photocopie par rapport à l'original on a
souvent le sentiment qui manque un
véritable programme de droite et de
centre-droit à cette coalition
il se définit elle parce que tout ça il
est comment la primaire va régler tout
cela après bien il est bien forcé de
régler tout ça alors vous savez ce que
c'est on emprunte toujours un peu du
vocabulaire de celui avec lequel on se
bat ça va être moins tranchée mais oui
il va y avoir
le ce point de vue le match juppé
sarkozy
il peut pas éviter ça repassez omar dia
un élu socialiste qui lui résistent et
7d lui il s'appelle jean pierre masseret
il candidat en alsace lorraine champagne
ardenne il a décidé de se maintenir
malgré les pressions de paris ou à tout
cela en images
l'avertissement de solférino n'aura pas
suffi à le faire changer d'avis
jean pierre masseret persiste et si le
candidat socialiste dans le grand est a
déposé cet après midi sa liste à la
préfecture de strasbourg
nous pensons que c'est en siégeant dans
l'assemblée territoriale que nous
pourrons le mieux faire reculer le front
national en occupant la place dans
l'opposition parce que nous assumons en
effet ce rôle nous ne sont pas
majoritaires mais dans l'opposition on a
le devoir de continuer le travail qui
nous a réunis le président sortant de la
région lorraine était depuis hier sous
la pression d'élus locaux et des
instances du ps
un mot d'ordre se retirer pour faire
barrage au fn ya une prise de position
du bureau national et devra respecter
points au premier tour jean-pierre
masseret remporté 16 % des voix loin
très loin derrière le candidat
républicain et le parti de florian
philippot qui les deux ans 20 points tôt
pour parler de tout l'est de la france
va accueillir pascal jalabert
vous êtes le responsable du bureau
information au groupe ebra ce raison de
provence c'est la presse quotidienne
régionale qui couvre à peu près tout
l'est de la france
vous connaissez bien jean pierre
masseret a trop mais là je vais
découvrir tout le monde mais colin
grande découverte parce que visiblement
il irait vite voilà mes collègues du
républicain lorrain ne laisserait plus
qu'elles connaissent beaucoup mieux il
savait que c'était un têtu gros
caractère en acier l'eau ainsi on peut
dire donc
sa réaction n'a pas surpris il faut
savoir quand même que le parti
socialiste alors ça c'est par
amateurisme
soit c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé
n'a pas réussi à trouver nombre
suffisant de colistiers pour leur très
réaliste il faut rappeler la règle c'est
à dire il fallait que la moitié plus un
des colistiers signe un document
collective de retrait visiblement sa
masse en effet le cas si ça n'a pas été
le cas c'est à dire qu'il n'avait pas la
majorité pour signer le retrait de la
liste quelle chance at-il en prenant ce
type dans cents soit 6 cents de ceux de
résister seul contre tous jean pierre
masseret
s'il arrive à rééditer son score ce sera
déjà un miracle pour lui c'est possible
il peut leur éviter parce que je pense
qu'il va récupérer quelques voix
côté front de gauche côté gauche de la
gauche
mais il est clair que si florent florian
philippot l'emportent
il portera il faut savoir quand même
flou florian philippot n'a jamais gagné
de second tour en lorraine et a été
battu aux législatives il a été battu
aux municipales par la gauche
après des appels d' élus lorrains de
droite donc il ya quand même une
instauration le barrage de public health
a déjà existé prendre la parole sur wii
le premier sondage qui ont été publiés
dans le coin confirme ce que dit
jalabert dire que masseret se maintient
pour le moment assez 16% du premier tour
mais c'est plus les mêmes 16%
il a perdu la moitié de son électorat
socialiste il en revanche reviennent
vers lui des électeurs du front de
gauche et des écologistes qui se rabat
sur sa candidature trop content d'avoir
un candidat de vos six ans pour faire
élire philippe richard ça va être
suffisant sans doute pour faire élite
philippe richert peut vous savez avant
avant un deuxième tour
la messe n'est pas dite mais enfin sur
le papier je pense que philippe aura du
mal c'est vous attendez vous à ce que
cette région soit au centre de toutes
les préoccupations de la wii du
politique français très clairement oui
alors il faut il faut remettre le
contexte régional c'est une région qui a
été mal acceptée par les habitants la
fusion était mal accepté pourquoi parce
que les alsaciens
n'avais pas envie et il y a eu une
attitude des élus alsacienne de refus
vis-à-vis de la champagne ardenne et de
la lorraine
donc ça a provoqué les réactions un peu
le mécontentement plus de la capitale
imposé à strasbourg plus les prix chers
candidats
donc cela puisse jouer dans le sas a
plus joué pour le rejet fouet à votre
envie pour un sachant quand même que
vous avez en champagne ardenne notamment
des territoires où l'aspect social
l'aspect sentiment d'abandon pèse lourd
donc c'est un terreau favorable pour le
front national
on rappelle que brh et c'est quand même
la commune et qui vote le plus front
national en france c'est en champagne
ardenne c'est en haute marne et à ce
propos d'ailleurs petits détails a
souligné
il ya des communes de haute marne
notamment à côté de colombey les deux
églises où les gens n'ont vu que florian
philippot pendant la campagne il n'y a
que la philosophie lipow c'est à dire à
ces images il ajouté une campagne de
terrain à la notoriété dont ils
bénéficient au niveau national ce qui
fait que tu en penses d'oublier c'est
donc commencé comme cela depuis que tu
as fait des mois que nous voulons
absolument plus mon ski c'est évident le
sillon se tracent un petit peu plus
alors on va changer de région si vous
voulez bien tassés plus au site
en paca où christian estrosi affrontera
marion maréchal-le pen puisque le
candidat socialiste christophe castaner
s'est retiré voyons un peu
l'état des lieux du premier tour avec
françois moulin 20 heures les scores
tombent
et c'est la douche froide dans le camp
des républicains
christian estrosi la tête de liste est
largement devancé par la candidate du
front national
les militants sont abasourdis je
m'attendais pas à un tel résultat
vous en bord des larmes c'est une souris
imaginez
sourire crispé christian estrosi c'est
que la bataille est loin d'être gagnée
et il appelle un sursaut citoyen quel
que soit votre vote de premier tour
quelles que soient nos éventuelles
divergences
je vous appelle à faire bloc dans
l'intérêt de notre région
comment faire bloc au front national la
question s'est posée pendant des heures
au qg des socialistes finalement la tête
de liste christophe castaner n'apparaît
qu'à 23h30 devant les journalistes parce
qu'on est bon je parle pas de notes
scorn l'ordre vient de la rue de
solférino pour éviter une triangulaire
il n'y aura pas de candidat socialiste
au second tour comme l'a souhaité jean
christophe cambadélis pour le parti
socialiste avec beaucoup d'émotion avec
beaucoup de peine avec beaucoup de
remerciements que j'adresse à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui sont autour de
moi aujourd'hui qui se sont battus par
tous en provence alpes côte d'azur je
prends mes responsabilités en me
retirant de ce combat politique et
j'appelle à faire barrage au front
national
quel que soit le choix des électeurs la
région dirigée depuis 16 ans par le ps
n'aura donc aucun élu socialiste sur ses
bancs les six prochaines années
alors donc entre temps il ya eu ces
sondages
ces sondages qui donnent une christian
estrosi vainqueur sondage qui peuvent
surprendre
est-ce que s'il l'emportait ce serait
pour vous une surprise non ce ne serait
pas une surprise parce qu on a commencé
à être habitué en france à ce que dans
les premiers tours les front national
puisse faire des 35 40 % et que alors
que souvent c'est une tradition france
quand on dépasse 40% au premier tour non
il ya une dynamique on passe au second
ben non très courant ça se vérifie pas
parce qu'il ya vraiment cette espèce de
fameux plafond de verre qui est même un
plafond de briques que qu'on ne peut pas
franchir parce que la majorité des
français se servent de larmes du fonds
national pour s'exprimer mais ne
souhaite pas les mettre au pouvoir et on
retrouvera sa dans les régionales alors
c'est pas une science exacte il faudra
prendre ces fioles de pharmaciens pour
voir comment les choses se
se fabrique chemise ça fonctionne ou pas
voilà mais grosso modo ce ne serait pas
une surprise que le front national après
avoir marqué le premier tour au point
que les médias dits parle de la colère
des français
les français c'est 28% un bon ils ont
absolument occuper l'espace politique
c'est ça qui va surprendre c'est
qu'après avoir occupé l'espace politique
à ce point ils puissent le faire que 0
régions entre elles et que croyez vous
au 01 région c'est très possible ça
s'est passé pour le départemental 0
département alors dans les communes il
ya des situations peu différente mais le
zéro région est tout à fait possible
je crois que moi ce matin je l'écris
comme ça à une région c'est une
sensation à deux c'est une banalisation
du fn à trois c'est une déflagration et
à 0 c'est la démonstration que marine le
pen n'est pas capable de casser ces
plafonds de briques et c'est ça aussi
sur marion maréchal-le pen est candidate
en provence alpes côte d'azur à la 26
ans nouveau visage un petit peu de la
politique mairie sur une stratégie peut
être un peu différente de celle de
marine le pen on a l'impression qu'il y
a quasiment deux électorats l'électorat
peut-être du sud aux régions provence
alpes côte d'azur rhône est d'accord ou
pas c'est un peu l'analyse qu'on a
tendance à faire vu de paris il y a un
effet un ancrage front national qu'on en
fait attribué hâtivement ou rapatriés
c'est pas une terre très conservatrice
sur le plan de la société 1 le sud mais
par contre - marion maréchal-le pen a
besoin de militants elle a besoin de
jean de côle les affiches et lé retrouve
plutôt là dans un électorat bien plus
traditionnel du front national va donc
elle doit tenir en effet les deux
discours en sachant qu' il n'y a pas les
phénomènes de chômage de sentiments de
14 lycées qu'on peut enregistrer dans
l'espoir d'être deux campagnes
différentes entre le
je suis un peu de compagnie ferrand oui
elle même marion maréchal-le pen elle
est d'une extrême droite chrétienne bien
plus proche de jean-marie le pen que de
sa tante et elle fait une campagne où
elle dit tout cela quand même hein c'est
elle qui a dit on peut pas vivre dans la
république française et portel là bas on
n'imagine pas s'attendrir ce lancement
très différents à mayotte de
banalisation de succion deux campagnes
différentes qui symbolise deux fronts
différents avec en même temps un
ingrédient commun qui est l'hostilité à
l'immigration et l'hostilité et la
crainte envers l'islam au roland cayrol
pascal jalabert il ya une région auquel
on prête peut-être moins attention c'est
la bourgogne franche comté là aussi le
front national est arrivé en tête le
suivi des républicains suivi du parti
socialiste et on se dit que c'est
peut-être sur cette région qui peut y
avoir une victoire du front national
alors en effet les caméras se sont
beaucoup moins déplacé à dijon et
besançon
et si l'on regarde le premier tour à mon
avis à l'instant nous parlons c'est la
région dans laquelle front national a le
plus de chances de l'emporter pour
filmant telle combi monde réel pourquoi
parce que ça peut se jouer autour de 35%
35 36 donc là le front national et sur
des scores qu'il est en mesure
d'atteindre quand ça se joue à 50
il n'arrive pas il n'y a rien pas là il
en mesure d'atteindre à sachant que
françois sauvadet et s'intéresse à noter
qui est un centriste comme philippe
vigier dans le centre comme hervé morin
en normandie n'a pas réalisé un très bon
score de premier tour donc il a des
points à remonter
c'est à dire là et la gauche et la
droite ont besoin de report et
d'abstentionnistes remporté donc là ça
va être très très serré d'amour roland
cayrol sur cette région
c'est une région depuis longtemps le
front national est là il avait été
alliés au pouvoir régional
il ya des gens 24 heures de jean pierre
soisson s'il disait que lou il allait
patrouiller dans les bulletins pour
savoir s'il votait pour lui en fait le
groupe savait que c'était le cas donc ça
va il ya c'est vrai qu'il ya là dans
cette région il n'ouvrait incertitudes
qui est lié à une histoire un ancrage et
on risque d'attendre quelques quart
d'heure les résultats et région sera un
petit peu on va regarder de très près
dimanche dans cette région
merci pascal jalabert nous votre
éclairage sur tout l'est de la france va
maintenant parler de la stratégie du
retrait du parti socialiste que ce soit
dans le nord ou en provence alpes côte
d'azur ça pas forcément été très bien
pris notamment chez les militants
socialistes regarder manuel valls en
service après vente pour défendre sa
stratégie devant les députés un appel au
front républicain et à la mobilisation
des abstentionnistes pour le second tour
des régionales
nous prenons nos responsabilités
n'hésitons pas et quand on est à la tête
d'un parti
quand on a été président de la
république on fait des choix ne court
pas derrière l'extrême droite et le
front national
on est au clair on ne met pas au même
niveau la gauche et l'extrême droite moi
je ne mettrai jamais au même niveau la
droite républicaine et l'extrême droite
le désistement dans les régions où les
forces de gauche sont trop distancés et
douloureux pour les députés socialistes
mais la décision fait l'unanimité dans
le groupe il ya des interrogations mais
je rappelle quand même que cette
décision a été prise à l'unanimité du
bureau national bien sûr qu'on
préférerait ne pas avoir à faire cela
mais on prend nos responsabilités on
assume
il est facile de le faire quand on a une
idée précise de ce que l'on veut envoyer
comme message à tous les amoureux de la
république le ps mobiliser comme un seul
homme pour le second tour même si l'ailé
gauche du parti demande déjà un examen
de conscience après la disparition des
élus socialistes dans trois régions se
retirer sont tirées les leçons
sérieusement de pourquoi on en est
arrivé là c'est inconscient ou bien ou
bien c'est un calcul et dans les deux
cas je pense qu' il faudra dimanche soir
je vous donne rendez vous dimanche soir
en parler très sérieusement la
constitution d'un nouveau gouvernement
de gauche plurielle au lendemain des
régionales est l'une des pistes défendu
par l'ailé gauche du parti
voilà pour ce sujet signé jean baptiste
daoulas qui étaient à la sortie du
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale
alors on voit bien calcul ou inconscient
a dit christian paul
là aussi bien y avoir un examen très
précis dimanche soir des résultats et de
ce qui va se passer après oui avec
l'inconvénient pour les ex frondeurs ou
actuels frondeurs que encore une fois la
halle la gauche de la gauche se porte
pas bien dans cette élection dont ils
sont ils ont pas à l'extérieur du parti
un mouvement qui leur permettrait
d'aller bien loin parce que voilà tout
dépendra des résultats exacts
si le front national était lui malgré ce
sacrifice du parti évidemment ça sera
moins fort pour pau pour pour valls si
comme les sondages le laissent pour le
moment prévoir ça marche
je crois que ça sera difficile là pour
eur pour la gauche du parti françois
hollande madrid joue gros dimanche à
françois hollande il a
et là il a joué assez habilement comme
on le connaît c'est à dire qu'à la fois
il s'est occupé de son image personnelle
et son statut de chef de guerre garant
de la sécurité
et apparemment il sait pas mêler des
régionales nous savons qu'en vérité il a
été à la manoeuvre
entièrement entre lui et valls ça a été
une façon de graver ensemble ce qui
était en train de se passer mais je
crois qu'il n'est pas là il a pas et
intérêts évidemment à parler de ces
régionales il a intérêts lui à rester
dans sa cour
sa course celle des grands et celle qui
prépare la suite
lui aussi c'est à la présidentielle qui
pense et il faut laisser ses lieutenants
montrer pour lui que c'est bon pour lui
alors mercredi on va donner un coup de
projecteur sur la région nord pas de
calais picardie ou des sondages donnent
aussi marine le pen perdante
marine le pen 42 64 % des voix au soir
du premier tour dans ce fief de gauche
depuis 30 ans quelles peuvent être les
scénarios possibles voyons tout cela
avec louise civile
scène de joie hier à hénin beaumont l'un
des fiefs du front national à l'annoncé
des résultats
les militants exulte c'est magnifique
c'est inespéré inespéré je pense que
finalement le drapeau français retrouve
des couleurs ce soir et l'avenir sera
meilleur pour le peuple français
le deuxième tour on s'inquiète pas c'est
magnifique 42,1 c'est magnifique
le second tour est désormais dans toutes
les têtes et marine le pen compte bien
aller chercher encore quelques voix
tous les français ont leur place à nos
côtés dans ce grand mouvement de
redressement populaire et nationale avec
plus de 40% des voix
la présidente du front national fait
figure de favorite pour remporter la
région nord-pas-de-calais et picardie
mais la bataille s'annonce difficile
pour faire barrage au front national le
ps se désiste au profit des républicains
il n'y a que par la manoeuvre par les
laisser manoeuvre politicienne
d'appareils dont les français ne veulent
plus qu'ils peuvent espérer peut-être
encore se sauver se sauver la mise mais
pour les ténors du front national ce
barrage républicain reste bien fragile
ça ne marche pas pas
parce que entre les mots d'ordre est ce
que décident les électeurs il ya un
grand fossé
voilà le ps n'est plus du tout crédible
l'abstention des voix de gauche au
second tour pourrait faire basculer
cette région à l'extrême droite
un scrutin serré et un enjeu de taille
pour la présidente du parti qui
voudraient faire de cette victoire
un tremplin pour la présidentielle de
alors pour parler de cette région nous
accueillons un journaliste de la voix du
nord bonjour matthieu verrier
alors y ait aussi des sondages qui
donnent effectivement xavier bertrand
gagnant d'une courte tête qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ces sondages qu'est la
réalité sur place parce qu'on en est
c'est toujours très difficile à dire on
est à 53 autour de 51 à 53 pour procéder
bertrand donc on est encore dans la
marge d'erreur pour lui vaut mieux être
en haut de la marge que caen bat donc à
la 57e son âge alors j'avoue que j'étais
un peu surpris alors steeve briois parle
d'un décalage entre les appareils et des
électeurs et justement les appareils des
militants socialistes ont eu du mal au
début à à se mettre derrière xavier
bertrand les sondages ont tendance à
montrer que les électeurs eux ou un peu
moins de mal à encaisser le choc de
dimanche dernier et à se reporter sur
son ami bertrand c'est parce que contrat
roland cayrol que les que les
socialistes vont aller voter et xavier
bertrand mais il veut y aller selon vous
l'impression que oui j'ai l'impression
pour que ceux contraints et forcés et en
même temps c'est quand même une
tradition électorale qui est bien
inspecter en général par les socialistes
dans le en tout cas dans les votes dans
les circonscriptions uninominales
lorsqu'il ya désistement républicain on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya à peu près les deux
tiers des socialistes qui se plie à
cette à cette discipline est ce que
trouvent les sondages pour le moment
parce que la marge d'erreur elle est
quand même plus fait parce que si vous
êtes une édition des trois sondages
on est sur 3000 personnes et on a à peu
près les rien le résultat
donc il trouve à peu près ces mêmes
chiffres entre 60 et 70% des socialistes
qui se
qu'ils se reportent sur bertrand soux
qui me suffirait dans l'état actuel des
choses enfin encore une fois tout peut
bien sûr bouger et notamment le fait
pour certains de savoir que les sondages
donnent vous allez bertrand en tête peut
faire que certains du coup se disent ce
n'est peut-être pas si vous pensez qu'il
peut y avoir des mobilisations de ce
camp en disant bon de toute façon je
peux pas y aller parce que vu que les
sondages donnent gagnant c'est possible
surtout que dans le détail on voit que
les sondages donnent à peu près 60% de
report de la gauche sur les 7 vies
bertrand il en faudrait 75 % à peu près
6 si on reste sur une sur une
participation équivalente au premier
tour et on a 30 % d'abstentionnistes qui
se reporteraient sur marine le pen ce
qui fait quand même beaucoup ce qui veut
dire que on arrivera une participation
de 70% dimanche prochain ce serait assez
étonnant
ce qui veut bien dire aussi comme roland
cayrol que ces sondages peuvent avoir un
fort impact
il n'y a pas de raison on vit dans un
monde qui est un manque de communication
et de sondage
il est évident que c'est ça dont se
nourrissent les électeurs et on peut pas
imaginer que les médias et les sondages
et la conjugaison des deux n'est pas d'
influence merci beaucoup matthieu
verrier d'avoir participer avec nous à
cette émission on va s'arrêter à présent
sur la région ile de france la bataille
est très rude entre valérie pécresse et
claude bartolone comme vous allez le
voir dans ce reportage de cécile section
race blanche
encore une fois l'expression a mis le
feu aux poudres cette fois-ci claude
bartolone le candidat socialiste qu'il a
utilisé toute la journée
la polémique a enflé ce soir valérie
pécresse a décidé de porter plainte et
demande des excuses de manuel valls
ce sont des attaques abject
qui font honte à la politique me traitez
moi gaulliste social de raciste c'est
juste immonde
je demande à manuel valls de faire des
excuses au nom du parti socialiste
bascule dans la famille pour françois
fillon indigne et dangereux pour pierre
lellouche
la droite fait bloc derrière valérie
pécresse à trois jours du second tour
les sondages donnent les deux candidats
au coude à coude
carole pas d'excusés à part de claude
bartolone ni de manuel valls bien au
contraire il persiste et signe claude
bartolone c'est une faute politique
selon vous je sais pas il ya toujours
des noms d'oiseaux parfois c'était comme
ça en 2002 exagérés et qu'ils ont dans
les campagnes électorales moi je trouve
pas que ça soit très utile en campagne
électorale de faire ça mais il est rare
qu'on s'excuse après au contraire on dit
même pas peur
je continue quoi mais faute ou pas je ne
sais pas parce que pourquoi il fait ça
c'est pas juste par erreur hier à la ces
qui sait que son mais son message
premier s'adresse aujourd'hui aux
électeurs de la gauche de la gauche il
doit rameuté sur son nom les électeurs
front de gauche communistes verts du
premier tour et donc il leur fait un peu
plaisir en cognant plus fort contre la
droite pour que donner à une certaine
cher à cette union de la gauche car avec
un peu bricolé au dernier moment et ça
peut marcher ça peut avoir un effet ça
peut faire plaisir à des gens qui se
disent finalement barreteau il y va il
est guidé ça peut créer un petit peu
certainement leur site
alors ça peut faire peur à ceux qui sont
plus modérés il faut savoir là aussi
pesé le pour et le contre ce sondage là
aussi qui donnent au coude à coude avec
les pécresse
un tout petit peu d'avancé mais deux
fois c'est la marge d'erreur vraiment au
coude à coude avec un autre sondage
donne dans l'autre sens maintenant donc
c'est vraiment on est dans le brouillard
là ça ça va se jouer sur très peu la
discipline total de la gauche ou pas sur
barcelone
ce que les gens qui pourrait laisser
tomber le vote front national pour voter
utile pécresse au deuxième tour et
arrivé aux urnes des abstentionnistes du
premier tour à mon avis ça va être la
région qu'on va attendre longtemps dans
la soirée c'était comme ça déjà on avait
déjà annoncé c'était la région test ça
sera absolument absolument d'autant que
quel que soit le résultat de la gauche
et de la droite
le fait que l'île de france tombe ou
reste dans l'escarcelle ça va peser
beaucoup c'est quand même 20% de la
france c'est la plus grande région
d'europe celui qu'il a et il va pas
manquer de faire savoir qu'il l'a alors
au fil des scrutins le fn prend racine
dans les territoires français
je propose de faire un petit coup de
projecteur sur les ressorts du vote pour
le front national
près de six millions d'électeurs se sont
tournés dimanche dernier vers le parti
de marine le pen qui sont ils pour
quelle raison at il quelques éléments de
réponse avec stéphanie de pierre 28% des
suffrages au niveau national pour le fn
c'est un record
le parti d'extrême droite totalisent
plus de 6 millions des voix au premier
tour des régionales
d'abord vote de protestation le vote fn
est désormais aussi un vote d'adhésion
il y a au minimum un triptyque celui de
l'immigration de la sécurité et de la
critique de l'europe et de la manière
dont elle fonctionne qui sert de socle
et de valeurs auxquelles les électeurs
du front national
adder selon certains analystes les
attentats du 13 novembre aurait aussi
favoriser le front national cela a créé
un traumatisme et a montré à une partie
de l'opinion publique que terrorisme
étaient aussi portés par des jeunes
français éduqué dans les écoles de la
république ayant une carte d'identité
française
cela bien sûr à donner aux discours qui
était considéré comme apocalyptique du
front national un parfum de réalité et
parmi les électeurs très perméable aux
thèses front national il ya les jeunes
selon une enquête harris interactive
hier un tiers des jeunes qui ont voté
ont voté front national
les nouveaux dans sont effectivement une
partie des jeunes de la classe notamment
les 18 24 ans parmi
ceux qui ont le niveau de diplôme le
moins élevés qui sont des jeunes qui
très vite les premiers par rapport à
ceux qui ont les études plus poussées
rencontres toutes les difficultés
d'insertion sur le marché du travail une
large frange des ouvriers qui votait à
droite votent désormais à l'extrême
droite la vraie nouveauté c'est qu'il ya
maintenant des électeurs fn dans toutes
les catégories sociales
ces nouveaux électeurs permettront-ils
au front national d'emporter plusieurs
régions françaises
réponse dimanche prochain rock'n'roll
excusez moi une autre question très
simple le fn pour ce second tour at il
encore une réserve de voix
et tandis qu'elle sait que je pense que
c'est la question qu'il se pose lui-même
et est laquelle il craint de voir
opposer une réponse négative comme on le
voit dans les sondages n'y a pas de
réserve si il n'y a pas de réserve de
1er tour il peut y avoir des gens qui ne
sont pas allés au procès on fait souvent
comme si tu allais additionner les voix
du premier tour pour avoir le deuxième
c'est en partie vrai mais il ya dans
toutes les élections de ce pays un
transfert d'abstentionnistes et à 20%
c'est l'abstention 10 du premier tour
qui vont voter au deuxième tour et
réciproquement
il y en a qui ont fait voter et qui n'y
vont plus donc il ya un vrai changement
de 20 % du corps électoral et général il
est très proche dessus du premier tour
mais on ne sait pas on ne sait pas il
peut y avoir des gens qui viennent qui
vole au secours de la victoire comme
d'autres au contraire viennent pour
s'opposer au front national surprise est
toujours possible
la surprise est possible évidemment si
les sondages sont aussi bons
techniquement qu'il l'était au premier
tour ira moins de surprises
merci rôle au jeu nous avoir accompagnés
tout au long de cette émission spéciale
pour les élections régionales et katia
on vous donne rendez vous avec toutes
les équipes de cp et de public sénat
dimanche soir 19h30 émission spéciale
sur les élections régionales hainaut se
trouve la semaine prochaine mais semaine
prochaine très beau programme